the Russian foreign minister in New York
presiding over the U.N security Council
he said the world system was evaporating
before our eyes
now the United Nations centered system
is enduring a profound crisis whose root
cause was the desire of some members of
our organization to replace
international law and the United Nations
Charter with a certain rules-based order
nobody has seen these rules they were
not the subject of transparent
International negotiations
but Western diplomats said the decision
to call this meeting about the defense
of the un's founding Charter was cynical
the U.S ambassador said it was Russia
that had violated the charter by
invading Ukraine she'd come to the
meeting accompanied by the sister of U.S
citizen Paul Whelan who's been
imprisoned in Russia for over four years
Russia the convener of today's meeting
invaded his neighbors in Ukraine and
struck at the heart of the U.N Charter
and Russia time and time again has
violated Universal human rights and
fundamental freedoms both outside and
inside its own borders
Paul was a corporate security director
he had a job he loved a home a life of
Hope and opportunity
all that has been taken away from him by
Russia a country that Revels in its
culture of Lies
Mr lavrov also had an important meeting
with the UN Secretary General Antonio
Gutierrez Russia says the Black Sea
grain initiative expires on May the 18th
and there are doubts whether it will be
renewed
can the grain deal survive after your
meeting can the grain deal survived
so Mr lavrov simply admonished me for my
loud question but it's clear from a
recent conversation that I had with
Russia's Deputy foreign minister that
Moscow is not at all happy with the way
the deal is currently working and Senior
U.N officials are worried that Russia
won't renew it that of course would
greatly worsen the global food crisis
James Bay's Al Jazeera of the United
Nations
at least 12